[Musique]
salut à tous en ce moment on parle
beaucoup de la corée du nord
et vous pensez certainement qu'il s'agit
d'une simple la dictature marxiste et
bien sachez que vous avez plusieurs
décennies de retard puisque ça fait
maintenant plus de cinquante ans que le
pays développe sa propre idéologie la
pensée du métier et aujourd'hui je vous
propose de comprendre cet étrange pays à
travers le contenu est l'histoire de
cette théorie qui si on se fie à la
propagande a su transformer la corée du
nord en pays joyeux des prolétaires
heureux
l'accord et d'une
945 avant sable pays a connu une
occupation japonaise pendant 40 ans et
pour faire simple la séparation en deux
du pays qui en fait que l'accord est un
peu subi le même sort que l'allemagne
elle a été coupée en deux par des
libérateurs aux idéologies opposées
après la chute des forces de l' axe le
nord dirigé par kim il sung en gardera
une haine des américains et une volonté
farouche de réunification qui posera
d'ailleurs une guerre entre 1950 et 1953
à ses débuts la corée du nord est un
pays marxiste léniniste un euphémisme
utilisé pour dire c'est le mien comme
les autres et comme tout pays du bloc de
l'est
elle suit les directives des deux
puissances rouge l'urss et la chine à
partir de la seconde moitié des années
les choses se corsent la chine et l'urss
et un différend idéologique l'urss
pragmatique veut préserver la
cohabitation pacifique avec le bloc de
l'ouest et veut éviter une escalade
risquant de dégénérer en guerre
nucléaire
quand la chine elle veut continuer à
propager le communisme dans les pays du
tiers-monde et donc risquer de
déstabiliser le précaire équilibre
international les pays est parti
communiste sont alors sommées de prendre
position pour l'un ou l'autre camp la
corée du nord elle choisi de ne pas
choisir quelque chose classique dans le
monde soviétique commence par purger les
éléments contestataires les produire et
seysses et pro chinois sont virés du
parti et donc de la direction de l'état
c'est ce qu'on a appelé les événements
d'août 1956 le parti va se chercher sa
propre doctrine pour justifier son choix
de non-alignement c'est souvent comme ça
dans le monde marxiste il faut une
théorie qui justifie la pratique
progressivement l'idéologie du djihad
chez va apparaître cette idéologie met
l'accent sur le fait que la corée doit
se débrouiller seul et trouver sa propre
voie vers le socialisme
le mot en lui même est difficilement
traduisible en gros c'est l'idée
d'indépendance sur tous les plans
l'idéologie du che se décline en trois
volets
premier point l'indépendance politique
chaque pays doit respecter la
souveraineté et l'intégrité territoriale
des autres et traiter d'égal à égal
second point l'indépendance économique
le pays doit avoir ses propres
infrastructures et accès aux matières
premières et enfin troisième point
l'indépendance militaire après alizé
uniquement si le pays est indépendant
économiquement en disposant de ses
propres industries militaires
c'est donc une théorie est un programme
bien chargé pour un pays qui dépend sur
tous ces points des pays frères et qui
dans les faits aura toujours du mal à
assurer son indépendance notamment au
niveau économique
par exemple le pays a un problème
chronique d'approvisionnement en énergie
à tel point qu'en 1994 il a
temporairement
randonnée son programme nucléaire contre
une aide en pétrole au niveau
alimentaire ce n'est pas mieux puisque
le pays a été touché par la famine entre
1994 et 1998 à cette occasion on a même
parlé de cannibalisme
ça peut paraître horrible comme ça mais
dans la même situation vous auriez fait
pareil alors s'il vous plaît ne jugez
pas ouais si au départ la pensée du che
est un simple à jouer la théorie
marxiste léniniste officiel les choses
vont s'accélérer à partir de 1967 au
début de l'année un supposé complot mené
par des dissidents communistes et des
jouets qu'est ce qu'on a appelé
l'incident de cape town et suite à cela
le pays connaît de nouvelles purge des
têtes aux places et tombe au sein du
parti et dans l'eure mais on suppose que
le complot visait à empêcher le régime
de devenir une dynastie familiale mais
c'est doublement raté puisque suite à la
purge kim jong il récupère un certain
nombre de postes laissés vacants par les
exclusions devient le bras droit de son
père et la succession dynastique
elle semble acté après les épurations de
1956 et 1967
il ne reste quasiment plus que les
partisans des kim au sein de l'état la
marche volontaire vers le totalitarisme
elle commence le 25 mai 1967 kim il song
prononce un discours qui sera appelée
instructions du 25 mai et qui vont
notamment accentuer le culte de la
personnalité autour de lui à vrai dire
on ne sait pas très bien ce que
contiennent ces instructions du 25 mai
les historiens ne sont pas d'accord
entre eux la raison en est que et il est
extrêmement verrouillé on a peu accès
aux sources d'information primaire et le
régime a tendance à réécrire son
histoire pour glorifier ses dirigeants
par exemple kim jong il sera a
posteriori gratifié d'avoir
personnellement mis à jour le complot de
cape town toujours est il qu'à partir de
le culte de la personnalité s'intensifie
pour prendre des proportions quasi
divine
kim il sung est dorénavant
officiellement appelée grands leaders ou
chef suprême alors que ce titre était
avant réservé à lénine staline et mao
l'édification du culte de la
personnalité se poursuit et quelques
années plus tard en 1962 un nouveau cap
est franchi qui m'ordonnent
l'application des nouvelles consignes
via un texte dont le moment est clair
dix principes pour l'établissement d'un
système idéologique monolithique
c'est un texte en dix points
fondamentaux qui peut se résumer à kim
il sung et notre chef suprême
il est infaillible et nous devons lui
obéir cette soumission totale aux
leaders s'accompagne aussi d'une
réécriture de l'histoire
kim est un héros pierre la pensée du ché
aurait été imaginé dès sa jeunesse des
pèlerinages sont organisées sur son lieu
de naissance sa mère est considérée
comme
du peuple enfin bref vous voyez le
tableau cette même année 1972
l'idéologie du che pour officiellement
place aux côtés de l'idéologie marxiste
léniniste dans la constitution coréenne
comme boussole politique et en 1992 les
références au marxisme léninisme sera
supprimé pour laisser la place à la
toute puissante lancée du che à partir
des années 70 il faut bien le dire le
pays prend le large idéologiquement la
corée du nord applique sa logique
d'indépendance jusque dans son idéologie
et le gîte chez prend aussi un contenu
philosophique censée dépasser la pensée
marxiste
en fait le duce va surtout prendre le
contre-pied de marx le marxisme est une
philosophie l'histoire très mécaniste il
y a des stades d'évolution
politico-économique prédéterminé qui se
succèdent pour aboutir au capitalisme
puis au socialisme et les choix
politiques ne changent rien l'humain est
quasiment impuissants face à la marche
et à l'évolution des structures
économiques
kim il sung a affirmé le contraire la
volonté humaine et maîtresses du monde
et peut donc transformer la société par
son action consciente et volontaire mais
attention en volonté humaine
il faut bien comprendre volonté du grand
leader car la pensée de nietzsche et
aussi à comprendre dans son
environnement culturel à savoir le
confusionnisme pour faire simple le
philosophe chinois confucius a mis au
point un système politique basé sur la
famille dans le confucianisme la société
entière est une famille sur laquelle
règne l'empereur père symbolique de tous
ces sujets assimiler eux à ses enfants
qui vivent doivent donc obéissance toute
la structure sociale est imprégné de
cette logique allant de l'empereur
jusqu'au petit fonctionnaire local
chacun étant le père de ses subalternes
dans la logique du gîte chez qui
cherchent à concilier tradition
nationale et socialisme
le mélange de culte de la personnalité
stalinienne et la logique paternaliste
du confucianisme est un cocktail
explosif qui a donné naissance
un totalitarisme puylaurens dans cette
logique du cheo confuse et n le régime
lui même utilise une métaphore assez
parlante
la corée est encore leader en est le
cerveau le parti en ait les nerfs et le
peuple en est ses muscles
une précision également kim il sung et
présentés par la propagande comme étant
le créateur de la pensée et du che est
en fait c'est une création collective
est le principal artisan de cette
idéologie style réchappé de corée du
nord en 1997
manifestement il était peu satisfait de
son oeuvre
toujours est il qu'après les années 70
le régime est totalement aux mains de la
famille kim et le peuple sous l'emprise
d'une intense propagande déifiant le
dirigeant kim il sung père en 1994 en
ronde demi dieu sa mort physique ne met
pas un terme à sa carrière et il sera
nommé président éternel titre posthume
en 1998 sur le plan physique
kim jong il lui succède mais le fils n'a
pas le charisme du père et les factions
au sein du parti et de l'armée
longtemps neutralisées par les purges et
la poigne de fer du père se remettent à
rugby kim jong il pour asseoir son
pouvoir fait un pacte avec l'armée à qui
il permet d'avoir ses propres fermes et
que ses propres entreprises et donne la
prévalence aux militaires sur le parti
dans la gestion des pays et comme
toujours en corée du nord
ce revirement politiciens s'accompagne
de sa justification idéologique
le gîte chez reçoit alors la joie
intellectuelle de kim jong il
justification de son alliance avec
l'armée la théorie son volume grosso
modo la mainmise de l'armée sur le pays
est expliquée par le fait que l'armée et
non plus le prolétariat comme le veut le
marxisme et le moteur de la
transformation vers le socialisme
l'armée le riz fier et en pratique elle
sera surtout utilisé comme main d'oeuvre
pour les grands chantiers en 2012
kim jong il meurt à son tour et c'est
son fils kim jong-un qui prend la relève
il apporte lui aussi sa pierre à
l'édifice idéologique familiale et
prolonger la politique du son goût de
son père par la politique du bmj kim
jong-un y met l'accent sur le programme
nucléaire qu'ils relancent le
considérant comme un élément central du
développement du pays à la fois
militaires pour éviter toute invasion
mais aussi civiles car le pays a
toujours des problèmes énergétiques et
ça c'est un point qu'on a souvent
tendance à oublier en ce moment mais
pour le pays c'est aussi une question
d'indépendance énergétique
voilà pour l'histoire alors en conclure
eh bien d'abord que la pensée du che est
une idéologie bien pratique
elle permet d'assurer la domination
psychologique d'une famille sur tout un
pays tout en étant suffisamment molle
d'un point de vue pratique pour être
adaptées à chaque situation par une mise
à jour du grand leader et aujourd'hui il
se trouve que le nucléaire est central
dans la rhétorique politique de kim
jong-un le pays youn-jin son apport au
gîte chez est centré sur cette question
et toute la politique de kim est
compréhensible si on se rappelle de son
apport à la théorie maîtriser l'atome
lui permettrait tout à la fois de se
sentir en sécurité de parler d'égal à
égal avec son ennemi américain
il réglait ses problèmes énergétiques et
d'affirmer la validité du che en
réussissant en comptant seulement sur
ses propres forces
le tour de force de maîtriser l'énergie
atomique contrairement aux années 90 il
ya aujourd'hui peu de chances que
l'origine abandonne
nucléaire en cours de route les enjeux
étant bien trop grand et bien voilà vous
savez tout sur l'étrange idéologique qui
règlent en corée du nord
si cette vidéo vous a plu vous inviter à
partager et à mettre un coup double moi
je vous donne rendez-vous pour une
prochaine vidéo
d'ici là je vous dis portez vous bien et
à la prochaine
[Musique]